hey guys this is the report I'm still
Dave Rubin and I have to
up by favorite most enlightened guests
Kelly Carlin
Rick over 10 about that enlightened had
a too early for enlightenment I don't
know I
have I want to manage a team and rather
to her life or in like 10 min today
right
take my word for these are very
enlightened guess so let's get right to
it
gotta start with racism because that is
the big topic the week you but we kept
it in america
right now Donald sterling we now all
know what happened
so it's just passport and go to what
happened yesterday
which was Adam Silver the new NBA
commissioner laying down the hammer
let's go to the videotape effective
immediately in
I am painting mister sterling in
for light from any association
with the Clippers organization or the
NBA
in mister sterling may not attend
any NBA games or practices in
he may not be present any Clippers
facility
in and he may not participate in any
business
or player personnel decisions involving
the team in he will also be barred from
attending
NBA Board of Governors meetings or
participating
any other we activity in
I'm also finding mister sterling 2.5
million dollars
the maximum amount allowed under
the NBA constitutional okay so if you
were hiding under a rock
ten-second recap Donald sterling order
the Clippers
nine minute audiotape incredibly racist
while talking to his black and Mexican
girlfriend will get that part
me just a second I mean there's so many
layers that this I am
let's just start with just broad racism
its it hasn't gone anywhere has it a no
I I thought Obama got elected I think
it's pretty much cut the club that said
if we have a little deer
when Obama came in with their little dip
in a feeling like maybe we're getting
past this and we're post-racial
and now it's starting to rear its ugly
head again do you think that's gonna be
no yeah I think we'll Ford 10 seconds
when Obama got what Obama got elected
that's pretty that was amazing that mean
the fact that the guy was black
and had this weird name I thought
there's no way america's going for this
and they did it was great
but yeah it that it just pushed all the
buttons and all love the fear
the white males who are losing the
battle
sorry guys panda good run red yeah I had
a good run
the yeah it's it's now
it's now seeping out every corner have
our culture so his weird name are you
saying that's why they always say Barack
Hussein the
Obama as though they had that they do
that Rick racism did what I thought we
were past it but I guess there
I'll show you how smart are racist is 20
K
I would charge about I head I'm done I'm
a charger all day
hi come on down to I
to my Ford dealership but less Eurasian
pull my mother
that okay come on down to the bath house
unless you're gay
pearl this guy okay at the
he's not a very bright guy he wasn't
destined to be anything but briefly
lucky
yeah I will you guys feel slightly
different if he didn't have this crazy
history of racism you know Elgin Baylor
the former GM but the Clippers
had gotten into him I got into some
stuff with him there's been a
this slum lord issue that he didn't want
black and Hispanic people reading his
apartment
if this had been somebody that had a
perfectly clean record as far as we know
would you feel different about a Privett
phone
absolutely and there is an issue around
the privacy that phone call and cream
abdul-jabbar
wrote a great little piece ending for
time magazine online
and he talked about that part a bit that
he'd didn't like that part of it
but yeah it might be like a michael
richards moment or something results
earlier in your nose but
the point that Kareem abdul-jabbar made
in and these other people is that this
guy's been doing this for years and
years
he's known has a reputation in the city
for being like this
and no one made a fuss about it then so
but it takes something like this you
know a TMZ moment in our culture
to actually pushed to push him over the
edge this new media we have
that you know they're discounting is all
that's just the alternate media or
that's just citizen journalism
as having gargantuan sledgehammer impact
on circumstances there was the kid
who had alzheimer's in schools being
bullied so you're
Aspergers yeah as burgers and install
any records the
the bullies and they sue him and so the
a the mass media took over
and they drop the suit may ran and hid
done and there's some other
circumstances like better
yes powerful but it is also there's an
issue i mean you know this was a private
phone call and I guess the girlfriend
today
within the LA Times a girlfriend was
saying that she did not mean for this to
go
out and she did not release it but there
was a third party involved we don't know
who that is yet who did
release it so do you guys fear that the
privacy thing we talk about privacy at
some level every week on the shore to do
more
in a in a little bit but that the
pricing has completely disappeared
because we've all said things privately
in private conversation
world the comedy world we can joke about
things that you do it publicly it could
be taken the wrong way much less with
uk2 privately
to do you worry about that we're losing
that at all
which in no way is a defensive anything
he said and in that
audiotape obviously I don't think that
we're yeah I i'm pretty much everything
I'm I'm afraid of losing
other kinds of things over that system
entirely
then just I said the wrong thing in a
joke I think we may have given up more
freedom than that
a for this artificial safety in that
system i dont I'm not sure if there's
any real safety at all
and and what they provide us with the
security system pic America
right I think they're even referring up
all too are individual safety when
they're recording their wondering when
we're going to wise up income
I'll americanism think in general though
I don't think we've really had the
privacy conversation yeah I think we're
all experimenting with this stuff
and I mean look at social media we we we
give away
all over privacy in order to connect to
people on Facebook and Twitter and all
those places
you know you sign it away when you when
you sing download the app
and so we had to be really even begun to
have a real conversation about
I don't think I'd I don't think the
average person it's hit
their life yet yeah and when that does
then the conversation will really start
well what we're trying to do here which
is why bring it up every do you guys the
to me it seems like the NBA did
absolutely the right thing and Adam
Silver brand new guy you know david
stern's somewhere to live it or not
they did the right pane help up for
publicity goes up obviously this has
been going on before they knew about it
before it was okay before until
this former media got hold of it and
cook
aimed at like I said a guns on a and
they recognize that we have a set the
controls to shoot at
them with words and they're terrified of
these words
and they even said that they were
they've been wanting to take action
against him for a while but they had
they want a
lawsuits go down in the lawsuits kept
going down in his favor
so they really couldn't make the move in
my understanding is that he hadn't done
what he did yesterday
every single team was gonna walk off the
court last night yeah which relief at
all
I what back because I am even if they
just delayed the games a half hour
Amruta
TNT many SBA yeah other advertisers
already in the end
yes it was the advertisers that
motivated most to this story in our
board members long
ok table yeah pounding free access yet
what did you guys see the
video above the advertisers at staple
center they were literally covering up
advertisers their billboards for it the
Virgin America
yes we're going away yeah what kinda
racist has a black girlfriend we've been
talking a lot about this on the Young
Turks
Lancel yeah it was so what's going on
there with that mentality that you could
have a black girlfriend
and then you could say that this girl do
not bring black
good magical talented forget racist or
if you know any if you care at all about
basketball you would want to be
associated with he's an amazing guy
yeah it really well what how do you how
do you guys parts that level
Bracewell you know if that that kinda
racism in general is fear
love the other it's this it's a it's
your unconscious psyche
afraid of the thing that unknown the
thing that you can't control the thing
that
that is so different from you that you
can't recognize it
any it leaks out in personalities in all
sorts of interesting ways so
having a black or latina girlfriend you
can
fucker you know so you can have control
over her you can sexually dominate her
that's one way to deal with the other
the unknown
and the other is then to try to control
you know your public space and here's a
man
clearly a ton of money but you look at
the LA Times adds this guy takes out
once a month
you know touting amo I got another ward
with this order
total narcissist he wants to control his
kingdom
and that's one way another way of
dealing with %uh I'm gonna control
MySpace and you would get to come in and
you don't they mean it's
its it's actually not as strange as it
looks yeah is it also sorta that
plantation mentality like
you know we can hack it have the the
black girl in the house
and I don't have to show any lower yet
she's just for you
Tierney me it up yeah I think that's a
great analogy for sure
yeah actually last question is do you
think the NBA should force him to sell
because that's the one thing they
haven't done at this point expand their
some questions
as far as legality because they're their
bylaws are in public
so you know maybe the book the owners
rep to vote on it do you think they
should force it just a really
put the final stamp I guess so I don't
know much about that world but I
what is he going to do I want you they
really have it avoid
yeah get a oh yeah I was not welcome
yeah
hit you up to the games anyway so i cant
do anything with the quite alright well
hopefully he sells okay let's move on
the I thought this was fascinating there
is a new study released by the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences
claiming that one in 25 people
the better sentenced to death are
actually innocent that's four percent
so from 1973 to 2004 1.6 percent of
those sentenced to death in the US a
hundred thirty prisoners
were exonerated and released because
benefit death sentences account for 12
percent have known exonerations innocent
people
from 1989 to 2012 the study concluded
that the criminal justice system goes
too far greater lengths to avoid
executing innocent depended then to
prevent them from remaining in prison
indefinitely okay so there's a lot of
stuff here so again I wanna start with
the bride thing
where you guys stand on capital
punishment I have a feeling I know for
perhaps a regular eating disorders
a I believe you have the right in the
moment to defend yourself
like to animals and in that split second
effing and a dues some terrible so I
stop sometime I have to do it
but later as an actor revenge I don't
know
and oh and there are the dodgy cases is
so evil there's no fixing them
the problem with that is it opens the
gate to a system that goes yes take the
one bad guy
and five normal good ones too and I'll
take somebody's now
and then are privatizing just start
hoarding in a kiln letting people in to
keep my lights on
yeah which is what we're doing the
privatize presenting which is a whole
other topic of
topic but it's the same mentality have
seek
the reason for yeah you build that now
look for a reason to use it
yeah it its its its it's like the
marijuana laws there's no logic there's
no rationality around the step it is
pure emotion
you know the drug laws are all based on
you know wanting to control
a populations do that in this is the
same thing there's no actual proof
anything that this reduces crime
that love people who are in force you
know law-and-order people who actually
work in law and order
are against it because they know it
doesn't reduce crime
it costs more to have it I it's it's the
most
here rational system possible and
I don't want the state in charge up
deciding who's I
what this new study this means that
there's a good percentage of people who
are definitely in a center being put to
death
yet so I I'm clearly for years before
that yeah right back
they're mostly dead in here a half an
hour their spirits gonna its shell by
the time you killed again right I mean
look being put in jail for life isn't
that much better
a obviously but at least you're
breathing so it a little bit better
shepper I totally agree with edited
sleepers which also makes no sense I
butch jet that I think about earlier
than they did not should be you know
about other people up for death row from
wall street I went after I
so that's okay I'm not sure it has got
it all worked out with and %uh strive to
absolute
I'll crooks that the rule I and II a
statistic that California would save $1
billion dollars over five years by
replacing the death penalty with
permanent and president
alright so that being said so if you
take that so if you take the financial a
go and take
before percent which is a big number
anyway do you think there's any number
that would flip
the the people that are for the death
penalty is there any number that got up
to 10 percent
yeah cuz I don't think they would change
their mind I don't think there's any
empirical evidence
that would cause them to change their
mind I think people who believe that an
eye for an eye
is right is this just the way they
believe that they don't care how many
innocent people happy
I guess not but it's not been a superman
the new collateral damage Superman he's
mad to some guy knocked his mom over so
goes to three apartment buildings in a
blows
one aimed at now the other people at my
kids Crayola
you know whatever you did something to
me personally about this is the first
crash Bang
that kinda made of people you think you
may kill I just got here did you just
look it was imperative he did not go
over buildings corn silage ruining life
that shot the former with horns all
about after
I'm sorry betsy meritcare paragraph
and them mentality
that mentality is the same thing as a I
am
you know we're doing this for your own
good liar you gotta die for her home got
a lot of the innocents have to do it to
protect you
it's becoming evident it's a broken just
says Testament thinking or two as we
know
the culture wars right now is Old
Testament verses
rational science people that's where we
are America early for thirty years and
it's its heating up now and but it just
because I become so obvious
you know when you look at just the
numbers and then today out last night of
course in oklahoma
yeah a horrific horrific big
went to execute this man and they've got
new medicine
and a he woke up and he was tracking
everything in the butt Ameritech forty
minutes later really like
do we think that maybe that qualifies as
cruel and unusual with and you know if
the death penalty was so good maybe
they would have to do the thing where
the people that or press the button at
once so you don't know who actually did
it or the firing squad right
or some other people blanks because they
don't want to leave with sober really
okay you it seem to be able to find more
people
willing to to actually kill them yeah I
know it's it and then
the fact that she's she's not stopping
executions and her stay there just gonna
wait two weeks and try to sort this out
yeah
because that would probably be mad are
going to pay bottle what do we do know
me
I what do we do to reform somebody's
people could yet there are the people
maybe the Hannibal Lecter is
you know that really head be reformed
River put back into society
but we have plenty of people that go to
jail for life for good job perhaps their
lives that
that can be reformed anything that we
make people more hardened criminals
when it actually help institutionalism
what happens
in those walls and those prisons each
changes people they go from humans to
animals a
I was just watching a front line the
other night a about
a solitary confinement and it it
dehumanize these people to the point
where
I can imagine them ever functioning
outside as well as again I don't know
what the answer is it's
it and get you know that's a former
torture yeah
and do what they do to americans a lot
of torture stops happening americans all
time
yeah lot more and more and more like
against all treaties everywhere
yeah when we closing that gap both know
what happened orgy what happened to
president what Ryan me what we thought
was the guy that said
me and Shannon at the weird name bright
yeah okay for you know you're right that
all around
something okay a let's move on let's
talk about the
environment I thought this was really
fascinating if you don't think
were altering the crime in your not big
on Climate Change
maybe a little more evidence will prove
it to you I so there's been a major
major drought there saying what are the
biggest if not the biggest rout ever in
california is happening right now
and workers in Northern California right
now
are engaging this massive mission to
move 25
million baby salmon from five million
hatcheries
to the ocean so that they can breathe
and live lives in grow
a we've got some voters so this is
they're just moving them in their
meaning there's a lot of famine in those
trucks
there's a lot of negative earnings and
those trucks yep that's right
we've got 10 the salmon flowing through
a pipe
so then they height they're literally
piping them into were taking them from
that risk they will die
where they are because of the drought
and our plumbing anti-russian that we've
got one more
at him being released into the pacific
hmm
okay cells ceremoniously deposited
yeah break your life watching one of
those artificial insemination minute
ever
some larger levelers I
very much like but hidden video then put
it in the bush in and then perspire
that's right yeah are we totally look
I'm a guy I know I'm making a bid a job
I don't have any empirical evidence that
is this is absolutely climate change I
that I roll your eyes trying to be a
little more highbrow back I am
yeah all of our environment stories I
could just at the MU
arm number I look we don't have any
evidence that this specifically is
because it's something that humans have
done
to the environment we keep hearing more
and more about the stories
and species that are going extinct and
and climates that are changing and
changing topography in all this stuff
are we just gonna just simply destroy
this yr
a the earth is pretty resilient
considering media rights and head
like that some little little more I
we personally our phase may be done
the phase up this form a biped may be
done I think something's gonna come up
and make it the numbers the numbers may
be done that early
largeness the only way we may get back a
bunch
this this whatever this is we I mean
unless they come up with some
super neato thing that can reverse all
this real quick
the scientists have a decided that yet
we're we're already
on a thus the slippery slope downhill
a mars thats but mars up now
but you the whole point going there to
back it up right they all a book lol
gets gets all like it moved the iron ore
out a bit but that's the thing about
this %ah fishery thing which is
you know I guess part it was that they
care at
if they let them go their normal route
is not enough rivers and streams they're
gonna take a left turn is a right turn
at some point or whatever but anyway
are salmon aren't these the fish that
are more
earned and then they go down there
little saying they go out the ocean they
live a life like oh hey I need to make
babies and they turn around and they go
back up the
how are they gonna do that partook but
so that a little confusing 10 go to the
coastline to wait for their truck to
show
I like friend
on the vehicle that my truck that father
hey that's actually really funny like
they get dropped over the ocean
it actually changes everything that
they've I
really concerned about this part we need
this week to apply and
third so we're not scientists and I know
we're gonna have time to cited your
YouTube thing but you wonder why there's
an amazing that mean I think maybe I
need to come back to life for the salmon
if you wanna know why senator so healthy
person eat just watched a documentary
because you their whole life is going
swimming upstream and you can see other
building their muscles
any then becomes beverage with omega 3's
in the fatty acids that we need
so we're really screwed up some serious
that the thing to I'll I when I read the
whole article about this is that you
know the reason we're doing this
okay yeah for the salmon and everything
no not really
it so that we can have locks on the east
coast for all people so you're saying
the bagel lobby
dont think any other battle of the great
value your
editor and and you're depositing them
into Pacific which is now radioactive so
it's going to be lock seller
I we talk about Fukushima a couple weeks
ago there there say Shema
yeah exactly they're saying that it it's
not that the levels are
you know not going to affect humans but
who knows that the end is one of these
when he hears it might but
here's my everything too weird spending
all this money to take up the sweet
little fishies and drive the
thing what be nice to use that money to
actually
fixed up the hot the the issue as we've
got a bit like right some alternative
energy week you know it's just
so that's the part that that always
fascinates me goldberg dress
the so that's the part that always gets
me because the people that say but we're
not doing you know climate changes in
actually happening they seem to be the
people that are more interested in money
but it seems to me there's also a lot of
money that could be made in going green
and you wouldn't be hurting anyone try
that the
the disconnect that I don't understand
yeah it's always the
yeah but I got this stuff already put in
yeah we got the oil pump that a lot
don't pull
every oil palm bout with so much I wanna
get
to build wind when leave tapped or
not when it's this much and I gave up
this much money to start
all over again slowly build and market
as opposed to rock n roll
Lismore armored I guarantee you know
these these big oil companies they do
these ten years an REO
things they're they're looking at this
step they they get where they're going
to have to go
because they want customers they wanna
make money in 10 15 20 years
but you're right they want you know
squeeze every little bit out before they
yeah make the big turn so there is this
just the next step in evolution that's
probably been going on forever never
will just get to a point where we
ravaged this planet so much that we just
have to go somewhere else
I mean that sort of what's basic measure
about right we're gonna have to go
somewhere else
and they will probably do it there to
like that would have it I was about i
think is I believe you just did that yes
it was very good
I but you know while where this version
averse consuming species
we're pretty much this work parasitic
predatory
threat to any place we go we put a flag
and we
photograph ourselves right thing but
we're already immediately killing
everything around us to set up camp you
know
about that there are other animals
they're already doing it will be there
absolute best at it wherever we go top
predator wherever
unless we show up on mars and then the
day we get there somebody that's a
little more advanced than ice also
realize that they needed to get there
too and they're gone they're a little
bigger
that all work out well for the humans
that's right we make good pets
back but my we will make we will make it
better
really well all right let's talk about
net neutrality would do in a bunch about
it
I really beyond the money in politics
thing I think this is the most important
thing going on right now
so the FCC struck down net neutrality
didn't look like they were gonna do but
they did
net neutrality the basic principle that
everyone deserves
mobile Internet access and that the
Internet Service Providers
have to provide the highway should be
equal for everybody
now they've flip that so that the
companies can brought all the Internet
so you don't think that's important to
you let's say you're someone who watches
the Young Turks there's a chance right
after watching this
and you believe an alternate media well
with Time Warner which owns CNN says
when we don't like the Young Turks their
not given appropriate message well then
they can actually start Prada Ling
the speed with which you get the Young
Turks videos get these businesses
hugely important and especially now
anytime when
the mainstream media has failed us
miserably and cable news is a disaster
and all that so again we'll start with
the broadening
was the internet broken I didn't know it
you know any was there was there really
a problem here that the FCC had to jump
in
and get involved it was here are you
finding that the Internet was pretty was
only broke into the people who were
suddenly losing their power and money
picnic that's who was broken the rest of
us were like a walk
we have more power and access to our
consumers and to our audience directly
now
this is amazing this is like you know
the sixties all over again but farrow's
right
place the face free let anybody
error-free love with other people a lot
of porn up
way right alright always you know that
the front-runner but yeah it was not
broken
I just love the way they're catching is
the FCC to their like trying to say
but its consumer if your gonna be happy
because when you're streaming your
Netflix video
there'll be no glitches because will
give Netflix and people like that
priority
which you know I get it at 2 a.m. when
I'm watching the bridge I wanna you know
avid
flowing crackly but a yab
this is all based on the fact that and
everyone to play
the fair don't worry everyone getting
there about this
so you give me the perfect segue so
we've got a quote from the FCC Chairman
he said very direct the proposal would
establish that behavior
harmful to consumers are competition by
limiting the openness
at the internet will not be permitted
now that sounds nice and that sort of
sounds like what you're saying but it
doesn't there's no
that nothing has no teeth in that
they're they're gonna they just decided
to change
what was working and then say well we
promise tonight screw it up
any for yeah but they're up for bid you
say fuck you know
here alright woefully of auto show is
about oxygen
is there anything we can do about well
first we gotta get
true though our voter fraud because
there are four Obama
through fuck 'em history and so make
sure you don't have that when I decide
to get boat and I'm the same guy that
thinks this is another important lot a
party that's the same exact mindset is
that is said artificial problem to take
command back
from people who were getting power from
those other stories we were talking
about earlier that you're changing the
way we make money you came here for two
hours now we gotta
workable the law yet talk with you going
with a little bit of a conspiracy theory
here could this possibly be why CNN
gave us three months or whatever it is a
24-hour plane coverage
because they want to keep our eyes of
the real problems
because they are owned by Johnny
corporate conglomerates that
gain access and gain the money that
you're talking about and when we're the
ones threatening
a course you can see it that way but
really CNN once your eyes just to be on
them they don't care what you're
ignoring
they just want their I mean they have
the best ratings in 15 years or
something like that to reset
it yeah so I i'm not a I'm not want the
people sitting in a room and you know
making up decisions about the you don't
need a conspiracy theory into the system
is already
you know against us cell yep that's my
personal view
do we need what you've been talking
about a couple times so far do we need
this
groundswell support starting at the
bottom
people taking to Twitter Facebook you
know the 99 percent all that
thing is that the only way we have a
chance to get this thing fixed when have
we not
mean when is that not been the case one
is that not work
yeah and always works same key
seem like everytime like works every
time to put an end to it
just gonna look for the key too busy and
other stuff I gotta do
something to do with some it'll help a
lock for me where's everyone at once
it's like one of those nuclear missile
things are two people that put the key
in birds and
everyone key turn our house and I do
believe that
innovation I mean you know the Internet
and
and everything around it you know is is
all about young minds innovating
E with things that we can even
begin to ponder and I I think there's
going to be some young
Turk somewhere in the back cover room in
hell be like
I figure out a way to open up new a
billion times this over here this space
and will all jump in there and the
corporation's ability
what there wasn't any water or stop by
any more
were all over there are you know knows I
the job in a good job at it
someone to do it again yeah that's the
way it is that's the way innovation
works that's the way it that's the way
our democracy works that way
evolution works happen box rapid-fire
yeah
yeah know Kelly Carlin you gave me a
little hope at the end of the second I
did not know
that there was hope when you when it
comes to the FCC but apparently there's
okay I was being a bit at the Internet
let's talk about the death of humans
have you heard about this a poses I'm
act
with had heard about this poses at
funerals dead bodies imposes
at funerals this is the new Big being a
but don't take my word for it
with the media the life of the party
even though she's dead
friends at New Orleans socialite making
Easterling through their power grand old
funeral down in the by you
now once told she looks
like sitting in a car scenery
to depict
back your heart the eighty
three-year-old daughter said her mom
loves the limelight
love the attention so there she was
kinda posed with the help with some
extreme
embalming yeah bear she is I mean she
look
stuffed in taxidermy and all that good
stuff but he didn't get enough to a view
this we got two pictures
other people that I had been puttin
poses post
posthumously for the dead guy is the guy
in the hoodie
media sunglasses for a little unclear to
me for a second and the people on the
right if his wife and his girlfriend
I'll rather get in return for more than
welcome back
wet weather is next in line look at this
guy he havin fun in the afterlife
wondering did he die underscored because
that's a little
right now got a pretty like hell but
he's wearing their that with something
yeah I was wearing a helmet as they had
a mother I say go for more of that kind
of stuff yeah I should be everything
everything that was the moment before
you die
you should be posted you know yousef
calling it the diagram above death yeah
I'm
yes see i think the whole museum love
these things yeah
right lol before yeah that such a move
would pursue that the guy clean in the
good
yeah I are the people fucking I did
grabbers left yet what about you
hale-bopp the guy doing the aura
or II KN yet that some blurry video icon
like 10 like johnny carson doing his
golf swing
yeah it might always wanted to be
thrown out a helicopter just left
wherever he landed yeah I'm guessing you
are a good side or
yeah I decided to go I see what pose
when I choose yeah it really don't have
to so that was my last question what
would you choose
here it is the for I
other for over okay okay right here
camera your debt
both but what about a bit wanna come in
by
it I
ok I had no idea you
a big question mark about a year ago
always always
from this seems this actually seems
kinda called me what we don't talk about
death or out we don't
Khalil nice or debt that the video it
was a celebration of this woman's like
they had are doing the things that she
loved
yes it's a little weird I suppose but
but other cultures I mean you know you
go to you go to India and
you know people are carrying the dead
body down to the gun geez and
burning the body is right there minutes
an event to family comes it
it's a celebration it's a you know
they're they're connected with
with it I think it's I think it's a good
I think it's a step in the right
direction they are you
yeah i wish i had. yeah Irish
yeah absolutely Irish knowing that I
awake ok yeah
they have a party it's a party we talk
about all that funny fun stuff the purse
and it's the kind of come alive
yeah stories and that had drunk at the
house lives on anywhere I love the
socialite I love it
and she guessed arrange the whole thing
it had ideas knew what she wanted in
you know colonia how soon until we do a
little animatronics with these people to
that's the the next essay right watch
out for the freaky guy that wanted the
love doll
yeah had a lot of the condo I
knock it off yeah knock it off but
good I'll do we need to discuss that
more
in this is it. we've talked about a
little bit on your show and i've done
your show and I feel like it is
something that we don't have a real
sort of healing discussion well I think
it underlies a lot of
what drives us in this country are our
consumerism is driven by our fear death
you know we don't have a quiet moment we
don't know how to sit still and not be
putting something either in our eyeballs
or mouth you know and
and thats that is a fear doubt that the
underlying you know denial
love that that great monster always
around the corner the
the great unknown the biggest unknown
bring us are sick you must give me
somebody
that the science is now
projecting that a person can live a
and the next happen this century the
wealthy should be able to get the
Noel easy a machine to keep them alive
for a hundred and fifty
exhaust have you heard about that seems
a bit by a hundred and fifty years 01
that lemme yes bring time share pretty
fuckin sure
well of rock and flower
I 150
God damn spurring time American Idol
89 yeah I
Jaa finally I was ready to be killed
after American I
to bring them back I alright let's talk
about love we're gonna and I'm loving it
has been eleven show so and with some
love
I this is really interesting a new study
conducted by researchers in arkansas
which is where I get most my studies
from
suggest that our pets might have the
same love the hormone
that humans have it's called oxy to
Posen and
let's look at some more info on binding
for humans oxy toes in or the love
hormone gets released when you're
cuddling are having an intimate
experience
researchers tested oxy chosen levels in
a dog
and ago after they hung out separately
then they let the two animals hang out
together for 15 minutes
after that they checked again the dogs
levels rose by
48 percent I which is about how much are
humans would change in a similar
situation
and a heavy even bigger number than that
the goats levels when up 210 percent
Tino implying that the goal with him up
with the dog is this what gay marriage
was gonna lead to
no but this is certainly yes PTL
not mean to they've been doing this for
thousands have your you
loving sheep and goats feel they can you
tell me
get lonely Stephen Stills put it best
love the one you're with I
I staggering
and it wasn't bad okay and in the latter
sorry
that my bad it was a cheap shot yeah
recur you are you an animal guy too I
know Kelly is a big dog dog lady on the
Big Dawg I
I'm a big and all rights person yes I am
yeah a.m.
so does this surprise you guys as animal
people I love my dog I am completely
confident that my dog loves me
well considering that we are you
involved from these creatures it doesn't
surprise me that we have the motorhome
owners
I mean if you if a view believe in
evolution it makes perfect sense and
yeah and I think they're finding out
more and more now that
animals have a real inner emotional life
any is there a chimpanzee suing his
owners yup have been treated like a look
at what time
they're looking at something crazy like
every
yeah you can cover every but they're
finally having that they haven't
enter a motion a life which you know
really then goes to
argument for we should not be animal
testing we shouldn't ultimately be
eating these
creatures and I would be involved with
element IQ
I can't do I hated pet stores you see
him as the time your thing in there
their Peter on those all bars on the
bottom there's a
that same idea you watching a pace
you're watching a go crazy
like a prison a yeah it is absolutely at
but my thing about this which is
I'm you know science is finding all
sorts of amazing things about the brain
and the body and its
it's basically you know it's it's
discovering you know why we
box ito said why we connect why week you
know
and the god thing you know the part
super brain that has that in it and it
all gets down reduced to cells and
chemicals and everything which
to me is depressing and a right yeah
shakespearian
you know sonnets and Baudelaire poetry I
i wanna believe in that and i think is a
away you know from you know being Old
Testament and then through rational
science important important but I think
you have to also give that
there is something else between us you
know yes it's our tito's and
and and what else though you know i
think thats exactly what I circle 10
times here so that part that part that's
between
science in the party bus that's very
human that wants to believe
that love is in some ox ito said or some
me to koreans if we were in Star Wars or
something you know like
ritual aspect I L I love comedy but
County isn't be making some big
can make hormones technology I love it
on a spiritual bomb cuz
the spiritual bond is I have a hunger
for certain things in my heart
and this energy comes in and starts to
fill the cup up I respond to that my why
I will
feedback at the start the loop going
because I on an animal level
I wanna be near it I wanna feed from it
some more but I'm a healthy level
that's what all up is based on
recognizing something that made you feel
good
that I need filled a yeah and I think
it's actually I think it's it is about
creating meaning in your life
yes it could be this chemical thing but
are mines these amazing
big frontal lobes are the things that
create meeting
and and that gives life its power and
and why we're here why we stick around
you know so
and science can't fuck with that you
know i mean it that is what happened
what we do with that
we've taken chemicals and made meaning
out a bit I mean look how amazing we are
you know sure that don't know dog love
each other but
may be there have any meaning around it
we need we would have a whole story a
rapid
yeah speaking of chemicals whoever yeah
complicated love all anything in all
reality Yahoo
the milder the sheep yeah page yeah
absurd going from from the chemicals to
to our brains how long until we put this
in pill form
because now it seems to me if we can
isolate this thing you're good at one
thing around here
it's putting everything in pill form it
will have a little oxy toasting pill
and your pop that with the by Agra and
there's your a rom-com
they never intended on the following a
lot I got
timing isn't government go on the road
my well you know I think actually it if
they could
putting a hill for my it could save us
all because it is the ultimate love
child flower power moment I mean it is
that
everyone took ecstasy at the same time
on planet Earth
we've come across a roster something
like really amazing el pais
protester up dust without up to 80 said
power
yet well guys this has been a loving
show as I fully expected it to be
yes any final thoughts on this letting
me know a
be good to each other a pretty good be
good to each other
be good to these two people especially
on the Twitter
their handles a write down below and
thanks for watching and we'll do it
again next
up